it's very shocking to see something like
that happen friends of hayden underhill
anxious and distressed watching the
pictures of a deadly crash in texas
you don't you don't know what to do and
especially being so far away from home
we're almost just stuck waiting for news
and it's
it's really hard for all of us here the
collision killing nine people underhill
and dayton price the only survivors both
from ontario both are studying at
university of southwest in new mexico on
tuesday evening the team was coming back
from a competition authorities say a
pickup truck crossed the center line of
a two-lane road and collided with the
van carrying members of the men's and
women's golf team this was a head-on
crash
seven people who were inside the van
died also killed a 38-year-old man and
13-year-old boy who were in the pickup
truck
very very tragic the national
transportation safety board is
investigating a 13-year-old child was
behind the wheel of the pickup truck
it appears at this point in the
investigation
that the left front tire which was a
spare tire had failed which resulted in
the vehicle pulling hard to the left and
crossing into the
opposing lane under hill and price have
a passion for golf both were part of
golf clubs in ontario price previously
played at mississauga golf course before
moving to the u.s for school he was here
what seemed to be 24 7 and
really was working towards
an ultimate goal of playing
golf at the university level and also
maybe even professionally officials at
usw are monitoring price and underhill's
recovery they're making steady progress
one of the students is is eating chicken
soup and they are recovering every day
it's a game of inches
i know hayden's a fighter i know he's
going to get through this and he has
tens of thousands of people behind him
rooting for him as well but the usw
community in mourning when one of us is
hurting
all of us are hurting left trying to
cope with the immeasurable loss while
pushing for the two survivors full
recovery
erica vela global news